the power of wolves and wolf dogs to
help people heal it's a hybrid animal
the wolf dog by the way got the genes of
both animals and in southern california
there's a unique wild animal sanctuary
giving at-risk teens a chance to work
with rescued wolves and wolf dogs the
goal is to help young people learn
valuable life lessons about forgiveness
acceptance and i would say above all
trust in this case jonathan biglyhotty
saw the impact of this wolf therapy
firsthand
at an animal sanctuary in the mountains
north of los angeles the haunting howl
of a wolf
comes to life
she she's not shy i've never been looked
by a wolf before
i think i've actually enjoyed falling
teo alfero runs wolf connection and
spends his days rescuing and
rehabilitating wolf dogs these two came
from came to us as pubs and we've been
loving them since so neither one of
these no not the bad side of humans
some other wolves that we have here are
like i said shy and skittish but none of
them are vicious this is gemma alfaro
who studies the animal's behavior says
science supports what indigenous tribes
have long recognized that humans and
wolves have been working together for
tens of thousands of years
so the wolf helped us activate a primal
side of us
that is more connected more grounded
more clear-minded we consider the wolf
the healer of the human heart
alfaro nurtured the wolves he then
created the first wolf therapy model a
holistic approach that helps both the
abused wolves and teens and he says it's
been 100 percent safe for program
participants people some of your
audience would go what if a kid gets
mauled by a wolf right we put thousands
of hours on each wall before they become
part of the program and in 13 years we
have a zero incident history in order to
be okay with who i am i need to know who
i am amanda bier a licensed psychologist
is the program's director when we talk
about release it's really about
acceptance in this exercise teens choose
a rock i got mine that embodies their
inner turmoil then lug that burden up
the mountain
it's my stress
like the wolves many here carry
emotional scars and feel hurt angry and
alone so the wolves that come here have
an array of trauma and we see the same
thing in the youth that come here from
severe physical abuse neglect sexual
abuse and then also young people who
have never been able to be seen
because the humans in their life want
them to be something other than who they
are she shares stories of the resilience
of wolves it's just natural
for wolves to accept the past
to make room for new things then the
teens symbolically release their pain
when edward amaya enrolled in wolfe
connection's eight-week program he
carried the weight of witnessing his
uncle's murder as a kid i lost a lot of
people
i watched family members pass away i had
my only uncle that took care of me in my
arms pass away i held on to those deaths
very
close i think that's probably why i
didn't
socialize because i didn't want that to
happen again reluctant at first he
joined the pack around a medicine wheel
a sacred space where it's believed the
body and spirit come together for
healing i just started crying and
everything just came out it was a big
turn for me being able to do that
just being in the presence of wolves has
been life-changing for many of these
teens julia gomez says she felt
neglected as a child and today battles
anxiety and depression
[Music]
but the poise and power of this wolf
annie inspired her to push on
even though she was
missing one of her limbs
she was still a warrior
and which really connected to me she
gave me the courage to to keep
persevering
[Music]
amaya and gomez are now working at wolf
connection knowing firsthand how the
program helped them to grow
regret
and what was that moment like and you
released
all of that it
felt like i just let like a hundred
pounds off my shoulders it felt like a
new power like it felt like a superpower
almost we call it hiking for the wolves
is migrating hiking with
wolves hearing them howl
leads to breakthroughs every day you can
see it in their face they're almost like
oh in that moment you saw
humans change in that moment i saw
miracles happening right in front of my
eyes for cbs mornings i'm jonathan
vigliotti in palmdale california
what an unexpectedly powerful and moving
really i love the idea of accepting the
past to make room for the future yeah i
never thought of it that way it's so
true
and we all know that the strength of a
wolf is its pack and they're stronger
because of that and i think that
representation for individuals going
through something is that you do need
people and you can lean on other people
to help make you stronger even when you
feel weak i like where he said they're
shy and skittish but never vicious
because i think when you look at them
you think are they going to turn but he
said they've never had an incident 13
years never had a problem and when you
say that i've seen miracles happen in
person very seldom did we get to see
that you're right very nice job jonathan
bigliotti